>> Harris: THE VICE PRESIDENT
MADE HER FIRST LATE-NIGHT
APPEARANCE IS TAKING OFF LAST
NIGHT -- THE INTERVIEW REVEALED
HER NEW POSITION OF LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA.
AND SOME GLARING DOUBLE
STANDARDS.
DURING HER TIME AS CALIFORNIA'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL KAMALA HARRIS
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR PUTTING MORE
THAN 2,000 PEOPLE BEHIND BARS
FOR MARIJUANA RELATED CLIMES.
SHE SAID THIS LAST NIGHT.
>> I STRONGLY BELIEVE IN THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS AGREE,
NOBODY SHOULD HAVE TO GO TO JAIL
FOR SMOKING WEED, RIGHT?
[APPLAUSE]
CONGRESS NEEDS TO ACT GOOD WE
ARE 29 DAYS AWAY FROM THE
MIDTERMS.
AS CLEORA VOTING FOR AND WHERE
THEY STAND ON THIS AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO VOTE
ACCORDINGLY.
>> Harris: DESPITE GROWING
CRITICISM THAT SHE HERSELF HAS
BEEN M.I.A. AS THE PRESIDENT'S
BORDERS ARE, HARRIS TOOK THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RIP REPUBLICANS
ON THE BORDER CRISIS.
SHE TOOK A MONTH TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT FIRST
SENDING THE BUSES FOR FILLED
WITH MIGRANTS TO THE NATION'S
CAPITAL IN RECENT WEEKS.
>> I THINK IT'S AN ABSOLUTE
DERELICTION OF DUTY.
IF YOU SEE A PROBLEM AND IF WE
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS
IT, THEN IF YOU ARE A LEADER,
PARTICIPATE IN A SOLUTION.
RIGHT?
WHEN WE FIRST CAME IN OFFICE THE
FIRST BELL WE PROPOSED WAS FOR A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP.
IT WAS TO FIX A BROKEN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, WHICH WAS
BROKEN UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
PARTICIPATE IN THE SOLUTION.
BECAUSE WE ARE OFFERING
SOLUTIONS.
>> Harris: IT WAS LIKE SHE WAS
HAVING ONE OF THOSE TED TALKS TO
HERSELF IN THE MIRROR COME IF
YOU SEE A PROBLEM WE NEED TO
COME UP WITH THE SOLUTION.
SHE WAS LECTURING HERSELF.
>> Raymond: SHE IS THE
BORDER'S ARC OF MOST WISE SHE
OFFERING A SOLUTION?
WHEN YOU WATCH KAMALA HARRIS
IT'S LIKE A LIVING WARDELL.
YOU KNOW THOSE WERE THOSE WHERE
YOU JUST GRASP AT FIVE WORDS AND
TRIED TO MAKE A SOLUTION?
NONE OF THIS MAKE SENSE.
SHE HAS A PSA FOR YOUR BRAIN ON
DRUGS.
THE HANG TIME HERE AS LONG.
I JUST DON'T KNOW WHAT THIS
ACCOMPLISHES.
BUT INCENTIVIZING DRUG USE?
AND MORE SLOTH FOR OUR KIDS AND
CRIMINALITY IN THE BORDER AND
SECURITY?
I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT HELPS THE
COMMON GOOD.
>> I AM CURIOUS ABOUT WHY NOW
WITH THE MARIJUANA.
AND WHAT KINDS OF CASES -- YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT FOR EVERYBODY,
OBVIOUSLY, NOT EVERY CRIMINAL.
BUT THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT IS LAW DOWN MIKE WATCHED A
LOT OF LIBERTIES GET PUT INTO
PLACE.
THERE ARE TENTACLES OUT THERE.
BUT WHY NOW?
>> Emily: SHE'S TRYING TO
CURRY VOTES.
SHE DOESN'T ACTUALLY STAND FOR
THE LEGALIZATION OF MARIJUANA.
IF SHE DID SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN A
RECORD MANY YEARS AGO.
EVERYTHING THAT SHE DOES AND ALL
OF HER POLITICAL POSITIONS
POLITICAL POSITIONS ALWAYS
REPRESENT WHAT SHE THINKS SHE
SHOULD BE SINGING MOST WHITE
PEOPLE FROM CALIFORNIA LIKE
MYSELF FIND IT SO HARD TO GET
BEHIND HER.
WE SEE OUR SOMEBODY THAT CHANGES
WITH THE WIND.
SHE'S NEVER BEEN CONVICTED ON
ANYTHING.
HER RECORD REFLECTS THE DEAD
OPPOSITE OF WHAT SHE IS SAYING
RIGHT NOW.
REMEMBER BACK TO 2010 WHEN SHE
STAUNCHLY OPPOSES LEGISLATION
THAT WOULD HAVE LEGALIZED
MARIJUANA.
SHE SAYS SHE FEELS DRUG SELLING
HARMS COMMUNITIES.
ONE LATER ON SHE SAYS WILL BE
FOR MEDICINAL MARIJUANA AND NOT
WRECK RATIONAL AND SHE LAUGHED
WHEN SOMEBODY SAID WHAT HE THINK
ABOUT YOUR OPPOSITIONAL
CANDIDATE, HOW THEY THINK THAT
THEY ARE FOR RECREATIONAL
MARIJUANA.
ALL OF A SUDDEN NOW FIVE YEARS
LATER SHE'S ALL OF A SUDDEN FOR
IT.
IT'S ONE THING THAT I FEEL AS
HUMANS WE HAVE ALL THAT FOR HER
TO SAY I NOW UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE AND I BELIEVE FIRMLY
IN LITTLE BENEFIT OF LEGALIZING
MARIJUANA ON THE FEDERAL LEVEL
AND HERE'S WHY.
HERE IS WHY I BELIEVE IN THAT
FOR RECREATIONAL PURPOSES.
BUT SHE IS NOT PART ARTICULATED
THAT.
SHE FELT HOT FORMING A SENTENCE
LET ALONE ARTICULATING WHETHER
THIS IS A MONO SERVED AS A DISH
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
SENATOR, VICE PRESIDENT, AND
STILL CANNOT ARTICULATE WHY WE
SHOULD GET BEHIND HER FOR A
FEDERALLY LEGALIZING MARIJUANA
AND HOW SHE THINKS.
I KNOW I HAVE MY OPINION BUT SHE
IS FAILING AT CONVINCING US.
>> Harris: 2,000 PEOPLE ARE
ALIVE AND, AS EMILY SAID, IF THE
VICE PRESIDENT WANTED TO FIGHT
FOR MINOR CHARGES ON MARIJUANA
USE, MEANING THEY WERE NOT
ATTACHED TO MURDER OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT, WHY WOULDN'T SHE HAVE
2,000 TRIES AT THAT APPLE?
IT'S DOWN MIKE >> Mercedes:
MAY BE, HARRIS CAN START WITH
THE VENN DIAGRAM.
BUT THE 2,000 CONVICTIONS A
CIRCLE ONE AND THEN CIRCLE THREE
OF POLICY AND THEN FIND THE
MIDDLE GROUND.
LOOK, I THINK THE KAMALA HARRIS
IS SO OUT OF HER LEAGUE.
SHE SIMPLY DOES NOT HAVE ANY
FOUNDATION.
SHE IS A FLIP-FLOP.
IT'S WHAT YOU: POLITICS THE
ULTIMATE FLIP-FLOP.
ON TOP OF THAT TREE DOES NOT
EVEN HAVE THE STRENGTH TO GO
TALK TO REAL REPORTERS.
SHE GOES ON LATE-NIGHT
TELEVISION TO GET HER MESSAGE
ACROSS.
WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP LED ON
CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM, WORKED
WITH DEMOCRATS TO ACTUALLY COME
UP WITH GOOD SOLUTIONS IN
DEALING WITH NONVIOLENT
OFFENDERS, NOT THE CASE WITH THE
DEMOCRATS COMMENCES ON TOP OF
EVERYTHING WITH BAYLOR FORM.
>> Harris: I HAVE A FEELING
AND WHY WOULD BE LATE-NIGHT
CLOSE.
BUT SHE DOESN'T HAVE THE RIGHT
ANSWERS AND IN THAT ENVIRONMENT
YOU WOULD NOT NOTICE SHE'S
GIGGLING BECAUSE IT'S A
LATE-NIGHT SHOW.
>> SHE FIT RIGHT INTO THE REALM
OF COMEDY.
HER STATEMENT -- IF YOUR LEADER
PARTICIPATE IN THE SOLUTION.
HELLO, POT, MEET KETTLE.
WHAT HAS SHE HAD A SOLUTION?
SHE WAS SENT TO UKRAINE TO STOP
THE WAR AND SHE DIDN'T.
SHE WAS SENT TO MEET WITH THE
EUROPEAN ALLIES TO STOP THE WORD
AND SHE DID NOT BEAR THE BORDER,
AS YOU NOTED, AND FOR HER TO
HAVE THE AUDACITY TO CRITICIZE
GOVERNOR ABBOTT, IT'S REALLY
FUNNY TO ME.
SHE MUST NOT READ REUTER'S BIG
PUBLICATION OF COURSE THE WIRE
SERVICE BECAUSE THE EL PASO
DEMOCRAT MAYOR HAS SAID MORE
IMMIGRANTS -- ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
INTO DIFFERENT CITIES, THAN THE
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR.
YOUR PARTY'S MAYOR AS A
DEMOCRAT.
HE SENT A THOUSAND MIGRANTS TO
NEW YORK CITY, 1,802 CHICAGO
APPEARED NOT TO MENTION
LORI LIGHTFOOT WHO IS SENDING
MIGRANTS, BUSTLING WIMP FROM
COOK COUNTY TO PAGE COUNTY, THEN
YOU HAVE THE MYSTERIOUS BUSES IN
NEW YORK.
YOU ARE WITH US LAST TIME WE
TALKED ABOUT THAT, SENDING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS BACK TO
FLORIDA TO WORK ON CAMPAIGN
RELIEF.
>> Harris: WHAT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT THE EL PASO MAYOR, SOME
HEAT WAS TAKEN THERE.
THE CLOCK BACK WAS PEOPLE KNOW
THEY ARE COMING, I LET THEM
KNOW.
YOU DON'T THINK THEY KNOW WHEN
THE BUSES LEAVE TEXAS AND COME
TO D.C.?
YEAH, THEY SIGNED DOCUME